recording in progress
okay
okay
great for people joining us we are
talking about trees
and their support in upcoming version 13
of orphan language
all right
um
tree traversal orders this is going to
be a big deal because this is very
related to the whole multi-computation
story so i'm going to be interested to
see what you have for tree traversal
orders
um so what should i be looking at should
i be looking at the um the reference
page
for traversal order
yes
how much does this follow what was in my
combinators blog post about these
different namings and things like that
so how much does it follow that
yes so the each of these
orders has different names and we have
included how you called it in the in the
blog post as one of the personalities
so you see the outliner in a router etc
in the middle of their page how did you
make these pictures
um
did them as great i mean they are great
i use them
what
i mean the code that makes them
i guess so
that's tim
well but i mean it's are they drawn or
is it code that makes them it's code
but he has his own system to make these
kinds of things
okay can we put it as a wfr because i'd
like to use that code that looks very
useful uh no
why not
because it's not a code in that sense
it's code underlying an editor that you
need expert knowledge to use
well we should have something like this
where we can draw diagrams like this for
more complicated fine that's so that's
easy to do but this is here's a very
general purpose system it's not for this
okay
um
so there are two types of diagrams in
this page so these first lines try to
explain what the individual parts of
ordering are and then further down
there are examples of the 12
possibilities that you can combine them
okay hold on so
eventually this will need to be an
option to map as well
well that's one part of the discussion
i don't know whether we want this to be
traversal order or to affect everything
else
well i mean we don't yet have the
equipment
to do
uh
to do this for map do we
i don't think so but
that's why this could be three traversal
order or we leave it as traversal order
and then well i know but the question is
design wise would it work for map
some orders perhaps not all of them
have we thought it through
[Music]
um we have thought about trees
no i understand that but that's not what
i'm asking so so the question is are
trees general enough i mean they don't
deal with heads for example and
expressions we can have heads which is a
different kind of thing from what we get
in trees correct
we here we have the data which is kind
of the equivalent
but in a sense the the nodes of a tree
are all of the same type while in in in
trees we have to worry sorry in
expressions we would have to worry about
collections of heads it's a bit like
allowed heads for a race what do we
consider
to be part of the
array hierarchy
yes
um
my point is that to understand the
difference perhaps this second diagram
is clearer first
which second diagram this one here not
the data set with all these 12 trees
no these are these are nice and i mean
this is this is useful
i think
it's nice it i'm just talking about
understanding
i mean it was even more useful if there
was some color coding that indicated
what's top and what's bottom
that's selected by the nest line
okay so let me understand this
so the first line is saying these are
the structures you should worry about
and then the other two are saying do you
visit them from top to down well they're
not the only structures you should worry
about
they're not at all the only structures
you should worry about
right i mean there are many possible
orderings and those are definitely not
the only ones
no but what we are saying is that we
have 12 orders
and it's a grid of three by two by two
okay but but let me remind you just as
you might know
about what the actual story with these
orderings is
um
let me show you a picture which i think
i've shown before
let's see here we go
okay
that's an ordering
right yeah
and in general
there are
large numbers of possible orderings
given by these young tableau and things
like that right
um
yes like
yes
so you're thinking of every single
permutation of the notes is a possible
order
well subject only to what's time like
separated
right the time like ordering has to be
has to be uh respected
but everything else
is up for grabs
you mean that for the young tableau or
in general because we have traversal
orders that go the other direction
uh okay
right so we have to go down up and down
but for example i'm looking at your
third one
in which you first go left then right
then left again
we don't have that particular one which
which is oscillating yeah i understand i
mean in general there are a large number
of possible you know orderings
and we can this is this is the old
problem how do we i mean this is the
problem which we're going to talk about
extensively in this whole
multi-computation business
what
you know
there are ultimately two kinds of
ordering that are relevant there's
traversal order of a static expression
and there is um
um
there's evaluation order
okay
in other words once you've evaluated
something then that defines
a you know causal graph of evaluations
and how you traverse that as a different
issue
like like for example do you evaluate
the third argument before the first
argument did you evaluate the arguments
in order
and then once you've evaluated an
argument
to
do keep reevaluating the result of that
argument or do you wait and come back up
and evaluate the function that applies
to all those arguments
did you get what i'm saying sure
but
i mean then the question is what's
useful
well yes roger
that's and that's what that's
i understand that question that question
is a question that i've asked for the
evaluation sequence for 40 years
right
and
i think now what we have is a beginning
of an understanding from physics
which we're hopefully merging with
computational ideas to see what what is
useful and the answer is that there are
a variety of kinds of reference frames
that are useful or that seem to be the
things you know that get talked about in
physics
and they're also the things that get
used in logic programming probabilistic
programming whatever else
i i'm i mean look the idea of having a
traversal order for trees the very fine
idea i'm just saying this is the
beginning of a story and we don't want
to lock ourselves out of
some
interesting part of the story by being
too naive about what we're doing here
sure
okay so
i can tell that an important thing you
know as a matter of our own development
is that we have avoided the evaluator
when we need speed
for and and sometimes for non-standard
traversal orders
but in particular not redoing things too
many times
so just do sort of a single pass through
for instance
yeah
you know um
and i think i'm guessing that we're
going to be able to do those with trees
and not have to go to
uh
uh what are you talking about i mean
that's not relevant that's that's not
what i'm saying
that what i'm talking about about
evaluation is not
i mean that's not relevant to this this
is the pure structural walking of an
existing structure not a structure
that's changing out from under one no
i'm not i'm just we have to if you use
expressions there is an evaluator in the
way and i'm just saying it slows things
down because it keeps doing what is this
what is this
is this
new or is this like millions of years
old
have you ever seen this
what is it
oh this is super old probably
well then why didn't it get updated
or revised
it should be
yeah we should work on this
okay
that's a lovely thing
tree pot doesn't support tree yet
what is tree plot
it's it
creates a graphics out of a tree graph
well it should support tree
so it comes from here right
come on guys
okay these pieces have to be connected
together i mean just have tree plot say
tree graph of the tree
you know if it's a tree to do a tree
graph on it for now
that makes sense
yes yes and we are planning to update
also tree form to have a closer
um
graphical style to tree
okay
um
okay
let let's look at this traversal order
thing
um
yeah so these are examples showing
number in the notes as you
visit them
god i wish there was a way to do that
without side effects
what do you mean side effect well
n equals one
you know n plus plus i mean
is there a way to do
this would be like a tree fold
does tree fold also have a traversal
order prefold is specifically depth
first
and why is that
prefold implements depth first
evaluation
that's what it does
i don't understand when when you have a
tree
and
it's gradually adding on more elements
to the fold
yes why does it need to be depth first
because it's it's visiting it's adding
more elements as it
goes down it's not adding elements like
you start at the leaves and you are
applying a function
to your subtrees
and percolating a value up to the top
you can't apply the function if you
haven't compressed the inputs to the
function but but would there not be a
function then
that would be a
progressively folded function just like
you you fold over a list why can't you
fold over a tree with a certain
traversal so scroll down to the
properties and relations on or
no it's on the tree map page
you can you can functionally do the same
thing as threefold using dream app
how
it's in properties and relations
don't forget the redness there
you forget that
don't forget that
right
you understand there's not a confusion
about that
is there a problem with that
no no it's just adding um
yeah okay fine
okay so where am i supposed to look
that's this example here
so this is mapping this function
that's doing what you're saying like
progressively mutating the tree
and the end result is that tree fold
ends up in the root
by the way i think you need to update
your documentation
i just did
moments ago nail check online
do i need to do it again
um
okay
uh
the question from ethan here are we
going to have html xml json examples by
the way
there
we have some examples on nest tree but
probably not in all of the places we
could put them
do we have a reasonable plan for
actually getting like xml into tree
form yeah we plan on adding that to
expression tree after 13.
okay
it's actually one of the main objectives
for sorting one
okay
okay um
there's some suggestions on the live
stream about examples about uh
creating trees and so on
um okay
um
right
these uh dan is commenting on a live
stream about should they have a default
they do have a default the default is
depth first isn't it
these functions do have a default yes
the default is depth first
um
okay
all right
so let's um
uh
right
okay well now where where are we looking
here so we're looking at traversal order
again
i mean this is a complicated subject
okay
in order why is that i don't understand
what this what this means that's a
variant of depth first that's only
defined for binary trees
and we don't have that in this version
why isn't it defined for any kerry tree
because it has a digital order
in order means visit your left subtree
then the parent and then the right
subtree if you have more than two
children then
you have more freedom
it's like visit some of the children
visit the parent visit the rest of the
day
why is it called an order does it not
have another name
not that i know of it's called in order
because
there's also post order and pre-order
that's what we're no but what it is is
it's in the order it's drawn on the page
right
uh no
yes
left i mean if you speak right
oh what do you mean why do you no no see
so you you went to the wrong
node
what is the order again
first left i need something with numbers
so i can
read it off
well those aren't binary trees but i can
make you how do i make you what's the
minimum way to make a binary tree with
numbers
complete carry tree
i say carry tree complete k airy tree
why is it complete carry tree
oh
i mean that's fine yeah i know what what
what's the difference what is complete
carry tree
i've never heard of companies h3 takes
the size of the tree complete carry tree
gives a full tree for however many
levels
okay
and then then how do i and so if i say
graph tree
of this
what the heck is that about
what's that about
um this is a bug i've fixed in the
prototype build um this is the prototype
built
yeah it hasn't come in yet so try
try running that in twelve three
to get the ground to get the tree
why is it so slow
all right what's the order now
so it would go 8 4
9
2
10
5
11. okay
you know what that's exactly what i said
or what i was trying to say
although i didn't say it properly it's
left to right order on the page
right
okay
i
i don't think that that communicates so
well right but it is what it is right
sort of in some way yeah what means sort
of it is exactly that an in order is in
order as it is drawn on the page right
that's what it means
no in order refers to the fact that the
parent is in between the left and the
right
the reason that that's natural for them
that's where the terminology in order
came from
[Music]
by the way has this been hooked up to
the code structure stuff in the function
repository
no
do you are you aware of it yes
we we we're talking to chris
okay
does code structure work on more from
language code does anybody know
so this is so this will make a tree
right from a piece of c code
and i assume it has a tree
representation in addition to this
this kind of representation
it represents it using code element
which is okay i understand that but i'm
saying that the just as text structure
which presumably you're going to have a
tree version of this
yep
so i mean this has
what is its constituent graphs right
so what are you going to call the
version of that that gives a tree
and so that is a tree isn't it i mean is
that
would that be
that is a tree
of your kind of tree right it has that's
a graph no i know this particular one
has got but i mean there's nothing
structurally about this that couldn't be
your kind of tree correct
right so the plan is to have
expression tree to be able to eat these
and
interpret it automatically
so expression three has a second
argument in which you can specify the
type of thing you are
ingesting and so it will be
automatically able to
detect some of them
expression tree what has a
but if this is a graph can't we just
shouldn't we just directly get a
tree as a
product i mean shouldn't we be able to
say graph tree of this
sort of can i guess but well but no but
it does it work or does it not work i
mean that says that is completely
different it's got noun phrase one no
it's so that has vertex
you you're looking for some way to
convert a graph to a tree and use the
vertex labels
as the data
which we do not have
okay although that seems useful
underlying vertex names
right okay you're just using underlying
vertex names right
okay but it does seem useful to have
that but this structure looks completely
different right why is the structure so
different
it looks like it's a different no root
what's the deal here i mean that seems
like it's the root here
yeah there's there's complicated issues
with
determining root vertex when you're
converting between tree and graph
or where
why
i mean if i took this graph and i just
said what's the vertex within degree
zero
why is that hard
well that's not necessarily what is the
root the root is just whatever hap
whatever layered embedding happens to
put at the top
which could potentially have nothing to
do with the direction of the edges or
anything like that i see
i see so this thing
in fact
this thing is not indicating the
directions of the edges and probably
should be
it doesn't know that this is a direct
graph is what you're saying
right
but so that arguably is a bug
in the in the graph representation of
constituent graphs here
because it should know
yeah so it shouldn't be ambiguous what
graph tree is doing right now and it's
just a heuristic
is it looks for the first vertex in the
vertex list that has a maximum out
component
and uses that for the root so if you
happen to have a root and then all edges
pointing away from it consistently so
can i say what the root is here yes
second argument
okay i wonder what the name of that
vertex is
what the heck is the name of that vertex
sentence one i would assume
lowercase
no i don't think so
sentence one though
well there there's a lowercase sentence
one in the
vertex list as well
this looks like the correct one
i don't know why there's a lowercase
sentence one as well
but i don't know what stuff one is
oh that's stuff it's it's not
you didn't it i think it is a lowercase
sentence one
that's not
yeah okay so that's the other thing is
the order of the siblings
you know
we also don't necessarily
get that know that yeah you don't know
that from a graph necessarily
right but clearly we should tag that i
mean clearly okay so for text structure
we do know it because it's just text
elements but they were turned into a
graph for this purpose with a special
layout and that's not adequate
um
i mean the graph layout is determining
some order that it puts them on the
screen so in principle we could match it
right
okay
back to traversal order
t-spec
okay
where is leftmost and the most
so we didn't we did not
in the last meeting that we discussed
this we decided not to have left most
innermost and innermost left most
because it was confusing that it
mattered what order you put things in
but all eight of those traversals in
your combinators blog
are the those are the eight variants of
depth first and breadth first
okay
and then leaves first to something new
okay
so
in the combination of things so so what
this is in the end is a thing that is a
generalization of lexicographic ordering
for part numbers
right
that's what this ultimately boils down
to yes
do you understand what i'm saying
um with the caveat that um
[Music]
you know leaves first you can't get that
pairwise
you need to look at the whole vertex
list but that's some
that's not what i'm saying what i'm
saying is no that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying oh i see i see what you're
saying you you're saying there is a
glitch i have examples on this page
comparing some of these traversals to
like lexicographic sort and sort if
you're interested okay okay yeah i am
interested but i mean you're saying that
that normal sorts can be done by
transpositions but the leaves first sort
cannot be
right
okay
so but i mean the main point is that
there is an ordering
how do you get the ordering out of is
there an easy way to get the ordering
out
do you understand what i'm saying
if i just want the order right i've got
numbers one through ten how do i how do
i get the ordering
where is it here okay
what's that is that
those are positions right
yeah so that's i sorted all of the
positions
in numerical order and then decreasing
links
but wait a second wait a second i'm
simply awesome i don't think that you
have the the most updated version of
this page
okay well i can rerun my okay just check
it please because i
just ran it
just ran it literally just ran it
i'll run it again
[Music]
but okay but i'm trying to understand
the
what i'm saying is
given a certain sequence of part numbers
every traversal order defines an
ordering of part numbers do you agree
yes
okay i want to know how do i get out the
ordering of part numbers to which a
given traversal order corresponds
probably the easiest way is to do tree
position of tree comma blank comma
traversal order
okay but is that is it isn't there a way
to just traverse it and and throw the
num you know what where am i
well you could throw
them yeah sorry you can sew it yeah sew
it i mean yeah so it i meant yeah so so
map has access to the data in the
subtree
okay i get all of this i still think
that for purposes this is a fairly
confusing area
and i think there may be an argument to
do something which i already did for the
combinators thing of actually having a
function that returns
the sort of a bunch of part numbers
with respect to these criteria
just like lexicographic sort you know
there is a a
a depth firstness so to speak well isn't
depth first but something different
do you see what i'm saying yeah so there
are orders defined that correspond to
each of the eight
depth first and breadth first orders
what is in what sense
like
a function that you could pass into sort
and
what are the what is that function
well one of them is lexicographic sort
the other one would be but but it's it's
not an easy is it sort of miscellaneous
it's a messy thing
right that's why i wanted you to update
because
jose and i hey let's take a look here
what was that function again tree map
traversal order
right but what i'm suggesting is
that um
that we have a function
that is us that
well even we have
you know possibly one of the sort
functions has traversal order because
you know look when we do so work for
depth first in breadth first
but not leaves first
i don't understand that statement in any
in any situation there are a sequence of
part numbers there is a definite
ordering of part numbers which
corresponds to the first order yes yes
okay so why could i not give that
sequence of part numbers and say
do leaves first
and then what i'll see is a bunch of
long part numbers coming first
right
or
you have the shortest numbers first
i thought leaves first was was going the
leaves first
is it not the leaves oh sorry sorry yeah
yeah longest positions
yeah
right
so my point is
it seems useful
to have something
which
will take a sequence of part numbers
okay so what you've done
here okay so
basically that's that's got to be doable
um
ian
you know leaves first
because
of course it's doable
yeah i mean there is an ordering so this
clearly is a function that that gives it
um
i'm not sure about that
um what do you mean it's it's it's a
definite order you've got to see what i
mean is you can't infer
where you can't infer the negative level
from a part spec
so i think what ian is trying to say is
that we can do sort globally on a list
of positions yes
we cannot find an ordering function i
know i keep on saying this yes yes
that's why this is a different function
does not sort right right right yeah i
agree with you this probably cannot be
done by pairwise comparisons yeah it
cannot i'm sure it cannot be done by
pairwise comparison there are only i
mean it's an interesting question what
foliations can be created by pairwise
comparisons that would be a criterion
actually which i hadn't thought of for
these kinds of foliations
this is what i'm saying
yeah
i wonder what that criterion corresponds
to
hmm
mean that that you know this is like the
story of reference frames and relativity
and there should be something to which
the insisting that the thing be able to
be done by local pairwise comparisons
corresponds
right
yeah that's leaves first it feels very
global in nature it feels like yeah yeah
it is pretty global right but the whole
point is that that sort
you know when
you know when you do sorting
there is considerable arbitrariness to
what matters the length of the list the
you know you know what i'm saying there
are a variety of things that can matter
um
uh
so you know our sort function just has
sort of arbitrary choices for that
because most of the time all that
matters is that it's a canonical order
but if you wanted to sort yeah i mean so
i'm suggesting that we have a function
that is
some kind of i don't know traversal sort
or something
or part
or um i don't know what the right name
for it is
traversal sort maybe which takes a
traversal order and sorts a list of what
it interprets as part numbers into that
traversal order
so it's something that only works on
part numbers kind of
well no you could do it to anything but
i mean look look roger the problem is if
it isn't lists of things that are have
an obvious clinical order let's say it's
lists of lists then you've got a whole
giant world of other things that can
happen
right you see what i'm saying
i mean i understand why we want this
function for illustration purposes i'm
just thinking of why yes well i i know i
used it a lot in the in doing stuff with
combinators
it was very useful to have that actual
map at or something like that or among
other things among a bunch of things i
mean studying how many you know what
depth things occurred at and blah blah
blah blah blah
now conceivably there are other ways to
do those things but i certainly found
that function useful but now the the
problem is
for example
doing this for things which are like
part numbers which are one dimensional
lists of of uh positions
it's not obvious that that's general
enough
but it's a vast kind of worms
if you say that the part numbers are no
longer quotes part numbers they're no
longer just linear lists that say which
which side of a tree to go on but
they're more complicated access source
you see what i'm saying
so what would happen for example if we
have a list of position specs which are
kind of disconnected so it's kind we are
missing the nodes to connect to some
position spec which is present there
so they do not form a true tree say
what are you saying
you mean there are things in the
ordering
there are there are nodes whose position
is not defined by the ordering so what
you're saying
well i'm saying that if we have a tree
and we extract all the positions then we
can do sort of the positions with
various traversals but if we take a
subset
of those positions
i wonder whether the operation is
defined
if i'm sorry if we take a subset of
which positions of the position of offer
two through three
so
right for example would would one two
come before three four in leaves first i
don't think you can tell
yeah if those are the only two positions
you have
yeah
it's like i see so absent a tree
you're saying without the actual tree
in place
right
because perhaps what we need here is a
map a three map indexed
with a traversal order and then you
visit the tree
and you can get there and and one of the
things you can do which is
yeah why not just have something which
is a
uh tree index list
which has a traversal order
right
what would that be that that's
essentially basically just tree position
with a blank pattern
i guess so
i mean i guess that's
is that a tree
no
so you're saying
if i take something like this
um
oops that's that's not the right one
and i say tree position
okay
great
so that was a traversal order and then
specify traversal order goes to breadth
first
uh some autocompletes missing there
do you understand
yes
what's that
yes we will add
what's that
bug put all before traverse order
all here
i'm sorry zero to infinity
whatever
okay anyway but i understand the idea
that will work
okay
okay
okay
um
well fair enough i mean how confident
are you about this design
well it contains the standard orders
and it contains the orders you found for
combinators
more
okay and and it's it's kind of a
complete table so i think that's a bit
shown in the in the table of 12
possibilities
and we can always generalize it we find
more i mean
more orders we just introduce more names
okay
that's nice i mean it's great we have
this
i mean we really should think should
this be treat reversal or should it be
traversal order
do we think that in the end we will be
able to use the exact same traversal
order for expressions
my only thing is we have
multiple concepts of how to
transform an expression into a tree
so if you use the same traversal order
but two different
um expression trees
it's going to be doing something right
let's call it tree traversal order for
now
it may subsequently just become
traversal order
okay that makes sense i mean unless it
will be really good to do a study of how
this could be applied to expressions
because it may be very obvious the same
exact thing can be done
i think the safest choice is treat
traversal order
okay
tree scan fine
position support
okay tree map at applies list of
positions great
position patterns okay great these were
these were things that i was reporting
right i mean i tried this and didn't
work correct
yes yes and in particular some of them
only supported one level
like a single integer index now they
support
full deep positions
okay so this redesigned extends extended
level specs what is that
right so an issue in with trees that we
don't have with expressions is that when
you map at a given level you have to
specify whether you mean the the data of
the tree or the tree itself
and so that's why the level spec has an
arrow with an element
and then there you say i want i'm
referring to the data or i'm referring
to the tree
and there is
i'm sorry oh here yes yes
then there is this original tree because
when you are mapping
you are changing things so
do you refer to the already changed tree
or the original tree before it was
changed
what does map do
map just wraps map is like
tree
except it inserts as a
as a tree and
and we are
this is something that affects the data
at a particular subtree
right so the typical operation you want
with trees is that you have data at each
node and you want to map a function to
all to a subset of nodes say
but if you are mapping on trees
then there is a question of whether you
want the tree before you
its internal nodes were changed or not
i'm sorry i say again what does map do
i mean map just wraps an f around
everything right so if i have this
expression right if i say in tree map it
would be like as if you inserted a node
above every existing node
oh for goodness sake
how do i get that what's that
how do i get that
as a as an expression
um
first convert it to a first do graph
tree right and then tree expression
whatever 12 3
that'll work
okay there we go
okay so now if i say map
f onto that at all levels
that is effectively the outer f's
are
applied to the
by when they
at the time when the outer f sees
something its inner f will have been
changed
right
yes right and that's part of the
evaluation process
so now what are you saying here
we're saying that
that if you do level spec arrow tree you
get this kind of behavior
where the f's see the other f's
okay
original
tree it would be each f gets the sub
expression of the original expression
without any f's
is that something we could imagine
supporting in map
no because we know how to put the thing
back together again
right i think this is a new freedom that
appears appears with three
and why is that again
i think it's with expressions would be
something like
mapping on the on a deep expression and
then the result we put it as head
only rather than replacing the whole
expression you just mapped yeah i get it
i think there is an analogy there though
we can always do the
mapping through the tree and convert at
the end again to an expression i know
one question is where the original tree
is the right name and whether it's data
or subtree should be the uh you know the
first two right what are we calling
the debt when you extract
don't we call it subtree as an accessor
when you're extracting the subtree
do you understand what i'm saying
isn't it cheap art or something
there's there's tree extract
okay but what are we calling i i would
have thought that this first case here
was more naturally called subtree
than data i mean then tree
well the description use the subtree to
describe it
yeah always the sign
okay now the last one where you call it
original tree
is it the original subtree
yes it is
that's what it is right
right
why do you say the previous
applications of f because it depends on
the traversal order whether they're
previous or not doesn't it
right
so you should probably shouldn't say
previous
um sub applications right applications
to the subtree
so i recommend just subtree in original
subtree then
does that make sense
okay
all right onward here
what's level spec all now
zero to infinity
okay
tree data
now take a level spec rather than a
position spec what's that about
yes
this is um
in hindsight and an error in there we
designed in the previous version this
function taking positions back in the
second argument and then we realized
it's much more useful to have a level
spec
so this is a
design change using the fact that it's
experimental
potential subtrees are levels specified
by level spec
so this is like a level this is like the
level function
is that correct yes so now tree data and
tree level
i would say both of those
sorry i don't understand what's tree
level
it extracts subtrees tree extract and
tree data extracts the data
right so these are all variants of tree
extract to extract is the powerful
function that can extract anything
and then
to help in the in readability we have
three data and three children
specialized in extracting a bit but tree
data
of a single tree gives the single data
tree data with a level spec is giving a
list correct yes yeah that's a key
that's really icky what was it doing
before
instead of having a level spec in the
second argument it was a position spec
what kind of position spec multiple
positions or a single position any
a single or list or anything that's
supported by tree extraction okay but a
single a single one there would return
the raw data not a list of data correct
yes okay so you've this is a mess
right because this is saying
i i mean i'm not really that keen on
this
i think it's a mistake because i think
that this i think this is a mistake
i mean
the mistake having the generalization
i mean it could be just a function that
extracts the three data that's what i'm
thinking because i think that if it is
useful to extract tree data on a given
level
the the problem is
that to have something where with a
single argument it's got a single object
with two arguments it's got a list of
objects that's really not wonderful
and the functionality where you can
extract the data i mean what's the
relation between tree extract or tree
part
tree extract right and this function
so this is this is going can you entry
extract use an arrow data
uh
part you can directly use tree data in
the position spec
tree data itself or our data no
literally use tree data in the part spec
or use zero their equivalent
yeah the the position spec for trees is
very ambitious following what xpath and
other systems do
so
so this is an operator form of tree
level is that correct
um
so but why aren't you supporting
the same kind of thing
that you showed in tree map
where you have arrow data arrow
so currently we only have extended level
specs but for example for tree map at
we're currently just thinking about
having
extended position specs
but that's not a bridge that we've
crossed yet
the extended position specs means
just like you can say comma zero and get
into the head of something you can say
arrow data here and get into the data of
something is that correct
in a sense but because because here we
have lists
we can also string things in the list
so you can have three two comma three
data and then you enter the three data
and you could even continue
within the three data
um sorry say that again
yes so
in the standard position specs you can
have a list of numbers and you
progressively go deeper
you can also
in the list of numbers you can insert
three data and then you jump from the
tree to the data of one element and then
continue within
that within the within the data so just
like zero you can continue within a head
too exactly exactly
yeah zero and tree data are exactly
equivalent entry extract
so again why is there a need for the
arrow data thing in tree map
because level specs don't have that
freedom exactly we're talking about
level specs not position specs
so so what we need to extend is level
specs
yeah
so why isn't it the same thing for a
level spec that i see a level spec
i see a level spec is just a number
and this is saying
the last number beyond the last number
so in principle we are missing something
in level specs because there could be a
level that jumps to the head and then
keeps on leveling so to speak
do you understand what i'm saying
yes so if you say level two
you say level two now on level two go
into the head
and then go down another three levels
right
and we don't have a way to represent
that right now
yes as i was saying that they love the
languages for positions and levels in
trees are more powerful than the ones we
have for expressions
right the problem here is that
um
yeah ethan is commenting level specs
with named axes connects back to tensor
operations that's correct
and we should discuss this in the
context of our
uh array summit that's coming up
okay
kind of important actually
okay
uh
all right let's see
um
wave is commenting it'll be nice okay
what happens with highlight tree would
be nice to show evaluation as
the successive lighting up of a tree yes
we've done experiments with that for at
least 35 years it wasn't very useful
back when we started off doing it with
things like trace
all right okay so let's take a look here
okay have i gone over most of the things
here that are relevant
i mean i consider this a little bit on
the messy side but i understand why
we're doing it and i think that's the
best we can do for right now
see see the problem is guys
this whole multi-computation thing
and the whole story of evaluation orders
which is what that is going to relate to
is related to this except evaluation
orders so this is this is the conundrum
there's both static
construction orders if you see what i
mean static expression traversal orders
and evaluation orders both have
orderings in them
making sense
yep
and
i think the parameterizations of those
orderings are really complicated and i
think that's for that we are going to
require and you started building kind of
a language for specifying those
traversal orders
but it's going to have to be generalized
for evaluation orders
for more complex traversal orders
probably for expressions
i'm just concerned that we're not look i
think with tree traversal order we've
got this definite thing where we're
boxing ourselves in enough that will be
okay
all right tree visualization
ah tree layout
okay
so tree layout is the analog of graph
layout correct
yes
specify the style for subject elements
by position what does that mean
it's a bit look what it's done in grid
or data set that you specify collections
of
of some nodes
and you can specify
the styles for them
so here here we have two sets of options
now what we call the global options that
affect the whole tree
and the local options that affect
individual nodes
i see that's what tree element is
exactly the tree element is the language
to specify locality in that sense
and how does that work now oh i see it's
position to style
wow how does that relate to what we do
in grid for example
i think we have a similar syntax in grid
exactly it's the same thing
okay
and that pattern could contain
data
well that that pattern could that
contain tree data
inside that pattern no so so these
either need to be explicit positions or
patterns that match explicit positions
oh why can't this be
at the tree that is
gotten by going 2 3 data 5 6
do this
so i'm saying
yes i guess eventually could be i mean
at the moment i'm just check just we
don't need to check the design is going
to work for that that's all
seems like there's not a problem with
that
when do we get hyperbolic tree layouts
um do you mean these um circular ones
with accumulation near there yes
you can probably get them for 13 1 but
there were things to be
sorted
okay
okay so now
tree outline what's that
what is tree outline
so yeah so this is a function that
existed already and um it's a collection
of openers
it allows you to
i never saw this
no i have never seen this
i never saw this
okay um
grumble grumble i never saw this this
was never reviewed
sigh
yeah we may have forgotten it in there
give a second
sigh
okay so here you now claim you've got a
truly random random tree
we need to look at this function in more
detail
this is this is really kind of
impoverished in my opinion
i don't know why it doesn't work if i
click that
we never reviewed this no way i would
have agreed with this
i just don't think this is quite right i
think the basic functionality is
interesting i just don't think it's
quite right and i think also that being
able to celebrate it across into
multiple
you know cells here will be very useful
see what i'm saying
i see it rather than a single cell the
whole thing
right i don't know what it should be but
i i think that um
yeah i mean that's reasonable to have
open subtrees but i'm telling you this
is not very good graphic design and i
don't think it's good ux either
can we can we come back and look at this
some more please and make sure we have
designers in the meeting
okay
i mean i would suggest
that this thing be a more obviously
treaty thing
or at least have an option to do that
maybe it maybe this case is a bad case
of a random tree
but just numerical nodes
what happens if i say how do i get a
tree out of a dendrogram
well let's find out
okay so here if i say dendrogram
does that make just a picture or does
that make a tree
okay so how do i get the tree out of
this
there is a tree here how do i get it
i'm not sure we are prepared for that
yet
okay
something we need
so that's just a graphics
i would assume
maybe it's dendrogram tree maybe we need
a dendrogram tree function
i thought we actually had something like
that we
have um yeah a clustering tree
does clustering tree return a tree
it returns a graph
it's probably wrong
that's probably wrong
in modern times that's probably just
wrong
we should look at changing that
it's not the best thing in the world but
it's it's better than having
you know the thing or maybe we call it
dendrogram tree and make that be the one
that produces a tree
and deprecate this one
do you understand what i'm saying
um yes
but there's got to be a way to get this
is a tree
get me the tree how do i get the tree
right right so what we have done in
other cases is to have an additional
argument which is we specify for example
whether you want a sparse array or
structure array or a normal array
i know i know i know i know but it may
be that we should look at these cases
and see whether they're see whether in
fact it's useful to have a graph whether
you always want a tree
well because we will be able to change
from one to the other
well not if we
with a with trigraph or graph three
doesn't matter only if there's tagging
information are you proposing to put the
tagging look i don't like the function
which ends with the word tree not being
a tree since we just set up a whole you
know graph tree family where it always
is if it ends with tree it's a tree
right right i mean i guess this function
preceded the world country i of course
it did right by a long time
i mean we even discussed the fact i
remember talking about this in the
context of trees and and maybe we can
you know
we got to figure out how to make this
thing a tree but we're probably going to
have a differently named function that
makes the tree
that makes sense
yes
um
marco's common thing something like a
dendrogram like visualization for tree
outline would be cool and and you know
that's a good question is is given a
tree if i just want to display a tree in
this kind of format is there a way to do
that
like i've got this tree and i now want
to draw it in dendrogram form can i do
that
not at the moment i mean
the plan is to have multiple
visualizations for trees eventually but
we are starting that process now
okay fine but so for example making it a
dendrogram it's a plausible thing
yeah there are multiple visualizations
for for trees
yeah
should they understand one of them but
those will be done with tree layout or
what
um
[Music]
i i don't know most probably it they
will require different functions because
each one will have its own
options to control
i see
so it's the analog of um
yeah okay fair enough well we should
inventory those
um
label collisions get extra ugly and tree
says ethan
what is this general status of label
collisions
for example in in geographics and so on
the problem is different in each
situation in geographics we always can
say oh this city name doesn't fit so we
don't show it but with trees
we do want to show as much as we can
so so the situation is different so here
it's more like a lighting we could
decide that from this
node downwards
there's too much information so we light
from that point
so this requires different algorithms
you know trees are complicated in case
we didn't notice that already
surprising how much structure there is
to them that is different from
you know it's it's interesting we didn't
tackle this before and um
we kind of always assumed that they were
sort of trivial but they're not well
someone even claimed that they're
universal like you can even like call
them expressions and represent
everything
indeed
you know
at some level the whole evaluation
scheme symbolic structure and so on
that is the core of the language
it's it's sort of it's a it's a great
example
of knowing enough to make it work and
not knowing so much that you freak out
because
at this point i know a lot more about
you know evaluation orders and all kinds
of pathologies that can happen and
non-terminating things and so on and it
will be easy to just say this will never
work it'll just always you know it'll
freak out
um but it turns out it doesn't for
reasons that are
you know subtle reasons of what people
choose to do
rather than reasons of what's in
principle there
wasn't it the case when you went for
infinite order evaluation
i mean until fixed point
wasn't it lisp before it had one step
evaluation yes let's pass one step
evaluation everybody told me that it was
theoretically impossible to have an
infinite evaluation
right
and they but they were deeply deeply
confused i mean they thought
one of
their their biggest confusion was and
the binding in a lambda
that if you say lambda xx plus one they
thought the way you evaluate that is by
temporary binding of x to x plus one and
they said if you have infinite
evaluation that temporary binding will
blow up
and it will
well it will if you do it with temporary
binding
no but with us too if you've sat um i
know but not inside a lambda
yeah
right right right right the whole point
about pattern matching is you don't have
temporary binding it is a pure symbolic
transformation
right and that's and that the problem
was that they were obsessed with the
idea of variables and binding and so
they were very confused
and like i remember
dana scott and you know when i showed
him smp
and he said i have this denotational
semantics that's a sort of general
theory of all programming languages i
said how does it cover this
he's like well it doesn't
it's like okay
what does it mean to have a general
theory then
the you know it has call by value call
by reference call my name
those kinds of things but this isn't
this is called by symbolic
transformation
which isn't really a call at all and
that's how one evades the you know
infinite evaluation binding issue
that's interesting and pretty damn
subtle
yes
yes it's one of these cases where look
the basic point is
it was obvious that you could make the
transformation work
if you started thinking about it in
terms of things like denotational
semantics your head might explode and
you might think that it couldn't
possibly work
right and um
yeah but i mean this is what we're now
trying to roll back as we talk about
multi-computation and we talk about the
idea
of you know multiple threads of
evaluation and so on and how they
interact
that's what we have to now resolve and
that's why i'm so
interested in these different traversal
orders evaluation orders etc
right because that's that's finally
nailing that issue
um
plus you know i've said a million times
i had these two
attributes of functions in smp that
determined evaluation order
which was simply incomprehensible to
people including me
[Music]
but you know this is the problem and
this is by the way i mean at a bigger
picture level the problem of
evaluation orders is the same as the
problem of reference frames
and i don't know maybe jose wants to
make a general comment but i'm thinking
the the the apart from that
i think that these traversal orders it's
about sort of information accumulation
what
you know often when you do them you have
to do more than one pass anyway
yes it's about yes it's but information
accumulation is the same story as
observers
i guess yes
yes right observer is
aggregating pieces of space time or
whatever right
so jose can you make a comment on you
know when you make a reference frame
when you make a um
uh
you know in general relativity what are
reasonable frames what are reasonable
gauge choices how do you characterize
that
by some continuity thing or what
i think that in general activity we
distinguish that the metric which is the
geometric thing that contains all the
causality information etc
from then
the coordinate systems or reference
frames right and those can be arbitrary
but there are some which are associated
to some preferred observers like for
example there is an observer moving
through space and it's sending light
rays and receiving them back
and it's constructing a frame
of of the vicinity of the world line of
that observer
yeah there are some some famous
constructions like fermi coordinates
which are which have a specific way of
being constructed and those are
associated to uh
to an observer
but but the important thing is general
relativity is that
for a given metric you can construct any
coordinate system you want it doesn't
matter which one it is it may not be
physical at all but it works in the
equations
i understand that but what i'm saying is
you know like for example
in the case of you know constructing
things for i don't know naked
singularities the avoidance of naked
singularities those kinds of things
don't you end up with these bizarre
foliations of space-time basically that
seem unimplementable
by a practical observer
um yes
but those foliations
may not be exactly may not be associated
to any observer at all but they are
valid
foliations
i know but the foliations are the
evaluation order
i mean look there's clearly that there's
clearly a relationship between what we
call an observer what we call a
foliation etc but the thing that i'm the
thing that i'm trying to understand is
you know we've got a traversal order
thing we've got these name traversal
orders great just like we've got these
name things like schwa
you know the schwarzschild solution the
you know inertial frames these kinds of
things in general relativity
my question is if we're going to say
what is a reasonable thing to construct
and what is not realistically
constructable that's what i'm trying to
understand
well how do we parametrize what i'm
trying to understand is how do we
linguistically parameterize all
reasonable foliations
because i mean right now we're just
doing that by names in in traversal
order
is there a more you know if you would
say you could say i don't believe in
symbolic expressions
i'm just going to name you know like
fortran or something i'm just going to
name all these different structures 1
through 14 or something right but i
don't believe in symbolic expressions my
question is when you're talking about
foliations what is the symbolic
extensible representation of foliations
well
i i think what we need to separate here
is foliation from observer observer is a
ward line of somebody going through the
space and that observer can define only
in a small region around him
a truly physical reference frame
not very far for if there is much
curvature if there is if there is much
gravity
it cannot be very large because
coordinates will save cross and there
will be
old things so there is a limit to the
size
of the physical reference frame but then
mathematically we can construct any
foliation we want as long as
it's made of surfaces whose orthogonal
vector is timeline
and that's the only restriction they
will probably have no physical meaning
at all but they are mathematically
correct i know but but they're even ones
of those foliations that get so wild
that you couldn't realistically expect
an observer i mean
my point is if we are simply
parameterizing foliations right
and we're doing so independent of the
place the space to which they are
applied
like inertial frames we can do that
in
well this is what i'm trying to
understand is like the part numbers are
an example of something which can be
applied independent of the expression to
which they are being applied okay
but but is it the case like let's say
that you combine you do two or you know
k passes of traversals different kinds
of of these name traversals
is there one traversal that could do it
all
so you only had one traversal
more efficient
is there another traversal that could do
it and would be i understand it's
calculus of traversals yeah what is what
is the algebra of traversals of how
different traversals can be combined
yeah i wonder if anybody's looked at
that
but i mean there's some you know there's
there's a point of being able to
understand it if you're going to use it
if you're building a language you kind
of need to be able to understand it well
i know that's the challenge right now
right the question is how do we turn
this into something that one can
understand
and you know note that
see this is one of the beautiful things
you know
we've all been working with the symbolic
transformation thing for decades right
but the things i was just explaining to
you about temporary binding and you know
why things don't blow up and so on we
never had to think about that
right right and so the question is for
thinking about you know right now it
looks really complicated you know or
specifying all these variations blah
blah blah it's like oh my gosh how are
we going to deal with this
but i'm telling you i think there's a
way to simplify it by thinking about it
the right way that is as
clear in a sense as symbolic
transformation rules are so that you're
not thinking about you know
temporary binding explosions and so on
right that is the challenge
i don't know how to do it
i know of a very practical utility of
what we do now which is as i said this
infinite evaluation is practical as it
is in many contexts
it's a performance drag
when you want to traverse a tree to
collect information
yeah i'm saying
so this is this is going to be very good
you know i understand that i mean it's
the same performance drag as saying
look infinite evaluation
is
in space-time it's like going to the end
of the universe before you wait yes
that's a good way of saying it yes right
pretty much i mean
so
you know it's clear that's not a good
strategy
in the case of an for example in an in
for example one thing we do not have in
the case of an infinite evaluation like
a combinator evaluation or even x goes
to x plus one right
we do not have a way of of of capturing
the temporary results
right take x equals x plus one there's
no good reason or another or non another
non-terminating recursion
like a combinator evaluation right
there's no good reason like in
combinator evaluation you know i wrote
this whole thing about looking at what
happens if you just go x number of steps
according to some evaluation order
right
so the whole structure what's that right
you know we're starting to look at other
infinite computations and it's pretty
useful to truncate them
you know so for instance
if you want th there's a grobnum basis
for no for non-commutative algebra and
it doesn't it doesn't terminate it's not
finite basically
but using the truncated you know some
distance out is often extremely useful
well isn't that like real numbers
finite precision real numbers are useful
right
right and i mean insofar as there is a
notion of computable numbers you can
just go computing them forever
but their truncation is useful
right right
is there a truncated infinite evaluation
that's useful exactly exactly so for
example with combinators i was wondering
if there's a way of representing
uh you know both the infinite trees as
trans finite nut you know numbers
and then the truncation somehow some
some orderly way to do truncations
and and that's the whole point of these
foliations is that they represent
truncation slices
right
that's the issue the issue is okay so
here's the way to think about it
if you have a um
if you have just a linear sequence
truncation is just stop at the nth point
if you have a thing
that is a complicated recursive
evaluation like a tree
stop at the end point doesn't really
make sense you have to say what is the
profile of where you stop
right
and
that's what we're defining with
evaluation orders traversal orders
whatever you call it
or you could do that you could take an
infinite given a traversal order you
could say go n steps with this traversal
order in this infinite process
well at least if we translate traversal
order to evaluation order which i claim
is doable but not trivial
right this is interesting stuff i guess
truncation is good when you know there
is convergence because if you truncate
something that is going to go very far
no no it's asymptotic series is not
convergent perfectly valid really good
i think that's a good example
right i mean i think it is useful
i mean look the thing with combinators
i mean honestly i thought my study of
combinations was pure
kind of um
uh well not frivolity but but you know
but it's turning out it's very
intuitionally useful for this stuff
um
okay anyway we should wrap up here but
but um
uh
um
um
let's see
did the random tree what do you mean by
truly around didn't don knuth send us
some code for some more random tree
that turned into a wfr i think
are you guys aware of that
yes yes and we have used those similar
ideas yes
okay what does it mean a truly random
tree exactly
yes it means that in the previous
iteration in 12 3 we were producing
random trees but they were not
homogeneously uniformly
constructed and now they are
but what's the big space in which they
uniform
um
yes so
different structures and if you permute
the elements the the data of the tree
they give different trees
bob what roger is asking is we can
imagine a markov process that makes a
tree
this is probably not made by markov
process this is some other form of
randomness for trees
what is the measure
in other words yeah can you explain that
well so for size n there's going to be
however many
trees of size in labeled trees of size
in
and we just pick one at random
i see
with uniform measure for finite trees of
size n
right that makes sense again this is
again the truncation process of so this
is like something like random songs we
should describe that on that random tree
page in which you know
that it's you know in this sense
yes
because i think it might also be useful
to say pick a random tree according to a
markup process
yeah
no but i we spent a ton of time you know
for these um random graph distributions
to to make sure that they're they that
they have the proper distribution so to
speak and people actually found it for
these degree graph distributions people
were just pointing out they weren't
quite right we had to go back and
uh
yeah well you can figure out whether
it's right but we're just making a
histogram
right
um
okay
yeah by the way by the way your comment
about world lines and observers um jose
is is more complicated right because in
the quantum case
the observer's not like no anyway just
there's just a messy thing the observer
is not localized in branchial space as
the observer might be localized in
physical space that's just a totally
obscure comment
um
i understand the quantum case is even
more difficult yeah
and that's
i mean that is the one of the big
questions
is in physical space we are a certain
size
you know a meter acro whatever we are
there is a question how localized or not
are we in branchial space
and that term and that determines this
question about the locality of the frame
um
it is quite lovely how all these issues
are converging
kind of makes it makes one realize this
is not actually a simple process as one
might have thought
i mean in other words one kind of has to
understand quantum mechanics to
understand how to do this um
uh
you know i mean the thing that i've been
wondering about for like 40 years of how
to parametrize evaluation order
um
we need an idea roger jose ian everybody
we need an idea
right of how to what is the idea
for representing foliations what is the
idea for the disembodied foliation i
mean in a sense part numbers are a way
of having a disembodied
single position
with the weird thing that just like
coordinates have ranges part numbers
have ranges you can kind of run out of
one out of expression space
you see what i'm saying but part numbers
are universal to all sorts of
expressions
levels are another example of where of
something which is kind of a universal
idea
in at least tree-like expressions and
levels are like the cosmological rest
frame in some sense
if jose at least understands that
comment i think
um yes i i understand there is some sort
of preferred foliation
right but that's levels represent
the kind of
from the roots of the tree yes that's
that's right i mean from the root of the
tree they are end time-like edges
to every point
well no that that i'm sorry that they're
not they're they are the thing which
corresponds to
oh gosh what we're calling generational
states
um
anyway well this is a this is a
different discussion but but we need an
idea we need an idea about how to how to
represent
um
how to represent it's sort of a
generalization of levels actually it's
not a terrible way to think about it
what is the idea that ian was was
showing in which structures do you first
consider and then in which order do you
visit them
you mean entry in traversal though yes
this first diagram that there was in the
page of traversal in which you first
select the structures you will be
visiting and then you give parameters
saying in which orders you will visit
them and inside them
i mean this is basically time-like
space-like isn't it
uh yes in this particular case
but perhaps there are others
for four
you mean other classes of evaluation
orders or other classes of structures
yes
so something that we have discussed is
that the first diagram seems to suggest
nesting
while we are not trying to communicate
nesting we are just trying to
break the tree into disjoint sets
which is clear there on the other two
but not not very much in the first one
i think that's not surprising
yes i think that that's the story of
time-like ordering it's because things
follow from things
and so they get more deeply nested
right um
that's important line the other two are
just saying
what do you do vertically and
horizontally
yeah i think that's less interesting
this is the true
you know foliation story right this
stuff here
wave is asking does the parameterization
evaluation orders include or separate
between random access orders and
connected orders
that's an interesting question actually
right that's an interesting question
does the foliation
um
does the foliation have connected uh
allow connected visiting
i mean normally they don't the most
common ones in relativity do not
you know you go
you know you have an inertial frame it's
just slicing it and you you don't get so
it's more like this it's the breadth
first case here
i'm not mistaken those are the
space-like slices
right
it does have two
levels which are tree levels
space like slices of tree levels
and a boost what is a boost in a
tree so when you say space like you mean
their space like separated
yes okay
what is a boost
it should be the case that on a binary
tree you should be able to do a boost in
which
on one side of the tree
you are visiting
things earlier than on the other side of
the tree
yes but i don't know isn't there some
crazy operation tree rotation isn't that
used in in um
uh
isn't that a rotation is useful for like
um self-balancing trees
which are useful for all kinds of
searching applications
what is it again
that's you you rearrange a few of the
nodes yeah tree opera tree rotation
you're finding a new
route basically yeah
i bet that that's the same as a booster
we don't this isn't something we have
i bet that's the same as a boost
oh well okay i gotta go to my next thing
but um this is lovely i mean
don't you guys appreciate how how
elegant this is all gonna be when it
comes together
yeah stephen do you want to revisit this
or do you think we are basically done
i think we're basically done i think
that we should make sure that the same
that at least the three of us are in the
conversation about foundation about this
multi-computational language design
because i think this is going to be
related and i'm a little bit concerned
that they meet things that emerge from
that where we say oh we you know now we
understand this i wish we did that in
trees
right
okay
okay you've been saying can we add red
black trees
that's a data structure
yeah it's a different thing we have that
don't we
i don't know
wouldn't surprise me if we do
right
okay and and there's also requests for
plot theme for trees do we have that is
that coming
we should
i mean we don't but i think that's a
good idea
fine
all right let's wrap it up thanks a lot
thanks everybody thanks to folks on live
stream
talk to you all soon